I'm gonna call them up one by one and
then we'll get started first of all
Kamala Lopez please join us
[Applause]
Paul Rodriguez
we have a guest who's not on the program
but were really thrilled that he's here
with us he was an executive at Universal
Pictures and was instrumental in this
film being made Shawn Daniel please come
up to join
and the writer and director of born in
East LA teach mudding all right let's
see if there's a next one that's yours
oh all right
when you when you read this film I think
you had directed one other thing before
a mockumentary right maybe maybe it's in
IMDB okay I did
and now I can't remember the name but if
somebody will look it up mockumentary so
then you directed this film yeah what
what was your impetus for directing I
always been Tommy Knight directed
together you know one focal point but
when we made this film because that's
what I had been doing all the Cheech and
Chong movies there weren't any outside
directors one time we used our editor as
a director so the studio would yell at
him instead of us and so you had no
reservations about taking the song oh no
you know this is the hardest thing to do
to write direct and star in the movie
ban he's like you know it's like you're
never off when you're a director you're
never off there's iliyan question but
then you got it you know acting it was
let's talk about the casting little bit
so how did you go about casting this
film
Paul I knew I was always gonna be in the
film I wrote the part basically for him
he didn't know at the time well I do I
remember I was working at the Playboy
Club here at CityU and Tommy went to see
me I was in-between this I was three
minutes he's a stripper strippers very
hard-working ladies and I remember after
the show I was so excited to meet you
and Tommy right I'm so excited and I
remember I was talking to you and I was
saying you know there because I think
you'll be perfect for I said are you
sure you weren't already done aka Pablo
at that point right I had done DC cab
first some 40 something now but nobody
remembers the only thing that people
stopped me on the street always was what
are you doing at the time when you got
cast in this film I had just arrived in
Los Angeles I was pretty much I had done
one small independent film prior to that
but this was my first big film after
college did you audition how did you cry
audition many many times for Harvey long
you think it's too early too soon I'll
be over there lovely the years have done
nothing to you
which I was trying to figure which came
into a distance trying to where you from
and it was Venezuelan Indian yeah you
know I didn't really like from like New
Delhi you know so had the Cheech and
Chong films been done for universal so
did you know each other how did the film
get to Universal well as teachers saying
Cheech & Chong's next movie and then
Cheech had the script he had this idea
for a movie on his own and he was gonna
sing this Springsteen song and he was
gonna be
and so I remembered that my bosses were
like okay great so it'll be like a la
movie I said well he's born in East LA
but he actually spends the entire movie
in Tijuana and they're like that's not
like up in smoke next movie and Tommy
isn't in it I know what the movie was
about was going to attract an audience
and sell tickets and so was it did it
end up being a hard sell with it was
raining scruciating yes so that way now
try pitching this movie today
Mexicans come over the border by the
thousands
[Laughter]
what it was was that I had at recorded
this song born in East LA it was myself
and so and he says I'm gonna take this
to Frank but but just for you it's not
just new drugs and but if you want to do
it I'm ready to do it sort of ready to
do it the green light for this movie
exactly so he gets fired and that leaves
me and Cheech with this script and new
management comes in and I said well
actually believe it or not this is one
of them and we finally got three and a
half million dollars and goes three and
a half million yeah put up for the film
and the truth is the marketing
department didn't believe in it the
person who believed in it was this money
it's like you know was
when when you put up a movie and the guy
you've been working with leaves you're
an orphan at any studio and happens
because they the next guy comes in and
doesn't want anything to do with the
last guys choices and you know goodbye
and this was already in the stream who's
getting ready to be released and did get
released and it was a big hit right away
and Tom Pollock who became the next head
of Universal comes in on Monday morning
after it opened and looked his board it
said buenos dias I was in the room
exactly what he said that's exactly what
he should have said yeah so you recorded
the song and made this video did you
have a movie in mind oh no no I'm not
really I was you know I was a record
person than we did you know I didn't
have it I was you know concentrating on
doing this video now would that was a
big hit and Barney's tell they the song
was a big hit it was number one and
radio him and so they'd be everybody
beat me to the punch we would think
there's a movie I think you're right
you're a genius
so it was shot obviously in Los Angeles
but also shot where else mostly Antigua
Wow yeah what was what was that like
getting done 30 years ago it was pretty
cool you know I thought it was very cool
there for like six weeks did the studio
know they were I told as few people as
possible you see back then 30 years ago
the one and all the Mexican was
basically an innocent pleasure with the
cartel that's exactly right
hadn't come you could still walk around
relatively you know you bribe a cop 20
pesos that was going rate and he's from
TJ so he knows not really I'm from
Sinaloa Culiacan oh but ironically you
shot all your scenes in LA you didn't
have to suffer story of my life I did
Crocodile Dundee in Los Angeles but you
shot a lot of scenes all your scenes
except for now and I found it was a
highly educated population in Tijuana
there was a very strong middle class
there of people that were not transient
at all and we got to know them quite
well and it was it was a great shoot the
only process you go through when
shooting the film in Mexico and
eventually everybody they say yes to
everything until they say no because
you're greater start now and you get
introduced this to introduce to this
concept called la mode either
grease the bite you look and they want
to bite before you let go I want to go
back to the song that you started you
started by recording the song what did
you have to go through to get Bruce
Springsteen's sign off in his people
well he has two of my kids now uncle
uncle cheesy no it was funny because I
knew when I wrote this song that that I
was sitting in my kitchen and I had to
write one more song for this album he
was doing this album that had videos in
it and and I was stuck and I was sitting
in my kitchen drinking coffee and
reading the paper and I was reading this
story this is actually a true story that
happened to this kid he was about 13 I
said he couldn't speak English she was
born in in u.s. and I think there he was
a little mentally slow and and he
couldn't speak is you couldn't tell them
and he got caught in a raid couldn't
tell him where he was was and who and
they deported him and he was wandering
around TJ for like a month you know
being parents didn't know where he was
and blue
I was looking and at the same time the
the Bruce Springsteen song came on the
on the radio born in he's still a and I
started cracking up and I said that's it
that's it you know I was and I so I
didn't know what the song born in USA
was about and not not a not a clue
I just know everyone's alive sang born
and so I had to go to the record store
and get the record coming
oh it's about Vietnam that's coming back
home there's a sizable well he'll he'll
relate to this I wrote him a letter dear
dear Bruce I'm a big fan and and you
know and I included all the lyrics and
then I sent it to him and he said okay
that was wow he did like wow Bruce and
then when I did the video I had to get
another permission and so he was he was
getting married and and coming off tour
and and going on tour again
and so finally when I caught up to him
and I had to go because I had a whole
crew standing by they're ready to go and
if I didn't get the okay and like that
day it was they were gonna pull the plug
and I call him and I locate him
backstage and Dublin Ireland and he
could hear the band in the background
were singing ball in the US and and I
talked to his manager and they he okayed
it over the phone and I could go on I
was like you know that's right because
the studio was looking for a reason to
just be done with this and so it was
okay if he doesn't have the song and
then came to the song and because he got
born in the USA Neil Diamond then gave
you the rights coming to him to come to
him there I was gonna ask you what that
was it was easy
yeah calm I think Luke might have called
him Adler hey Neil this is Lou we need a
song okay thank you was that truly that
was it so how long did the shoot how
long was the shoot it was six weeks yes
yeah it was like but it was like we
worked every day yeah
yeah every day and then and then came
back to LA and finished it off but it
was like you know I don't know if
anybody here has ever made a film but
when you're doing and you're shooting
you're just making bricks you know when
you're actually filming the film Jesus
and you got at the end of the day you
got this pile of bricks and now you got
to make a house side of it you know and
you take these scenes along that brick
doesn't fit Chuck then when we shot five
days and only five to buy and so you
know it was that editing process but I
knew that there was a story there there
was a feeling that was unlike many other
films there you just sense you were
working on something I won't say like
surprised everyone but it's just I was
as I was watching the film I think about
loopy Ontiveros and Stevie Jordan and
people like that that I passed on you
know if it has become a film where it's
like the litmus tests are being Chicano
you know yeah are you sure you're
Chicano do you have a copy of born in
East LA what are your what are your
memories for both of the shoot I
remember going to dinner with Daniel
Stern and he was he was very nervous
about having dinner with me yes I wasn't
I was you were no tell more of the story
again no yeah no one who stood me up no
he was really worried that big ceeze
married and he had and and and I
honestly his my fit was my first thing
so I didn't even didn't even have that
in my frame of reference
uh-huh so I was just utterly confused so
he was he was like a method actor no but
what I remember most about Cheech when
he when we were doing this film was that
I came to it obviously as a huge fan you
know like the you know he was like oh my
god Cheech I didn't tell you that
because I wouldn't get any weird idea
but um but I thought he was gonna be
like a real party guy like I was so
disappointing will ethanol oh he was
very serious he didn't smoke pot Oh
24 hours oh and also as as he mentioned
it's incredibly difficult to not only be
directing but starring and he was so
good at it and seemed so relaxed you had
Peter McGregor Scott wonderful producer
mates really had your back and you also
would watch the take which I thought was
really brave of you because most actors
after they they do the take they won't
do it they won't go and look at it but
we had to essentially we were one of the
first ones Jerry Lewis actually was the
first one that used video tape when they
were shooting and we picked that up
right away because there was no you know
we were comedians you got to tell if you
got a sense if the scenes working and so
we started watching his okay well that
was that was funny but coming a little
faster and maybe Pan the camera over
here when your every take you know
something you would call that's for
permission this was one of the first
films that used video playback uh-huh
we had to figure out a way to do it you
know because we had a camera and nobody
had ever done this before I don't know
least a long time and we you know where
to put the video camera do you put it
you know next to the other camera and
you're so you don't know where to look
you're looking at two cameras and sort
of finally a couple films into it they
filmed they figured out how to do a
video tab and then they could run it
through the same lens but before because
it's two cameras even looking and you go
back and you let me just say if anyone
if anyone of you ever get a chance to
work with teach here Isis this is this
man I'm not just saying this man has
been he's been the nicest most generous
funny guy and he I mean I mean really it
was uh I mean like she said I mean I
I was just I looked at you like I
remember the first time I met you guys I
just was talking to you and Tommy was
kind of like just the best friend over
the year was a lot of fun I don't know
anybody that doesn't like him I'm really
I don't if you're there I'll kill you
you know after the movie had this huge
opening weekend and after that Monday
and Tuesday and Wednesday there were all
these meetings like how come what
happened how why did this work so well
because no one was expecting that and in
fact we we asked you to come on in and
talk and it's because not only was the
movie just non-stop hilarious but it had
heart and that's what people really
connected with and they told their
friends this was before social media
this was when word-of-mouth meant
word-of-mouth yeah telephones and
talking and from Friday to Saturday to
Sunday the gross went up and it was
because the movie touched people not
just made them laugh but it really
really affected it would I mean
unbeknownst to anybody I mean it was it
was the top grossing movie for the next
four weeks in the western United States
and they're very well so how come
Hollywood hasn't learned that lesson I
don't know and how come they're not
doing the sequel and we're here thirty
years later still haven't done this time
this song negates I thought back then
that Mexican Americans or Latinos period
would be as common on television and in
movies as at least this African
Americans are you know but the yeah they
deliver the TVs to your house
[Music]
did you you haven't you didn't direct
another film after that no did you want
to yeah I did yeah I did I really wanted
to but getting the movie off is like the
hardest thing in the world
it's harder now than it was then and
it's it's just difficult and and you get
wore down you get one down that I just
like you know you get on a project and
you develop and you're down you're two
three years down the road and you're you
run into a blind alley a dead end and I
gotta walk all the way back out there
and do that I just it just wore me out
so I could make more money acting so I
started doing that but I really wanted
to direct and then after a while I just
didn't want to direct anymore because I
remember oh man all those days and blah
blah and you got it and the thing about
making in movies you start over so many
times you write it that's the first pass
then you rewrite it that's another pest
and you rewrite it and then you finally
get the thing with you were you a film
it and and then then you take that and
start over yet it is core it with the
string sound like man just get this
thing out in front of me you do it
whatever you think is fine that's fine
Theresa who is your director
photographer Alex Phillips Alex looks
Mexican very iconic worked with when
well and and all those guys and he was
Alex Phillips jr. he was he was
world-class cinematographer I was very
lucky to have him too and he was he
really took care of me and your editor
was Scott Conrad who had had no talk
about he's gonna kill me
Donn Brochu who was my brother-in-law it
was it was a real editor I mean he had
an Academy Award nomination for the
fugitive but but he's my brother in life
but he not anymore not anymore he did
really good but we we had a life after
this thing you know after the after
movie had been out like I don't know
five months something like that I got a
call out of the blue and
this woman named Sonia Levine and she
she had this friends of Cuba kind of
club that she ran out of New York and
she says listen I've gotten an
invitation for you to bring the film to
the Havana Film Festival would you like
to go yeah I wanted to see Cuba there
were you know Idol dad and so we took it
over there and it was a big deal because
we were taking an American film in a can
under our arms and and and the studio
was very nervous you know they do how
long were you in Miami I was in Miami
for you could somebody go get these
jokes on the way home yeah but we went
to the the Havana Film Festival and we
were just you know they didn't know
Cheech and Chong in because in in those
countries it's the biggest Latino Film
Festival in the world Havana Film
Festival and the most sophisticated and
a lot of the countries didn't know
Cheech and Chong pea it was all the drug
exporting countries that our films were
banned in like so they didn't I was just
a guy with a film you know and so it's
we started they started showing it I
just wanted to see Cuba you know it was
like and again we rented a car and took
off and it was totally different than
what I expected you know I expected
being a heavy military president's and
it was nothing there was no I never saw
a machine gun or a homeless person or
you know and did you guys know I went on
my own I swam there you know actually
actually I was very fortunate in my my
cousin my first cousin was ambassador to
Cuba from Mexico so I actually went with
a diplomatic thing it was great for
marijuana ya know as a human let me just
say that you know I hope it well I hope
I hope that the best but I know it
sounds weird to say but it I don't know
how you found it but it's the isolation
of it is made at the ingenuity of the
Cuban people and the beauty I mean it is
just stunning and I went through
cienfuegos I went all over
got a ball there man very educated Randy
- you would think that they were no not
at all cuz you don't over here we hear
about communist are they hate you and
all that not that I want communism how
did the film go over there the film we
were it started showing you know like
Midway during the week and I was I
didn't know it was either they were
showing that in competition and and I
was sitting there on the bar with with
my guide and and people would come back
oh hey come on I'll buy your verses no
no no you got those are the judges you
can't so how many beers do you think it
would take man for you know Sweden and
then we left and we took off for El and
then next the next week I get this phone
call like 2:00 in the morning
probably the services you want
everything what no what we won we won
best picture actually we came in third
in the official competition third play
with won Best Screenplay best art
production best something best scripts
best and and which I wrote thank you
much and and and we got this other award
the global Rocha award was named after
their most famous South America's most
famous movie then I didn't because I
took off but neither did I you know
we're safe then some other vehicle with
a beard like if you felt like they gave
us this the globe ever switch which is
the International Film Critics Award for
Best Picture so we and we were the most
you know awarded film of the thing Wow
our little born in East LA film but it
didn't really touch people and that was
you know that's the most sophisticated
audience you were ever gonna play a film
in especially in the spanish-speaking
world so it was it was a real thrill
unless so
unless I missed it in the credits I
don't remember seeing a maid with the
cooperation of the u.s. Border Patrol
well they don't wait to talk about it
this movie is not going to be getting a
White House screening yeah all I
remember I remember he was a big star at
the time and I remember him was just a
little bit of a yeah I tried to separate
you guys as much as I could because I
had one don't throw us together put
those guys together but that would that
was that Jan was a really good friend of
mine great guy okay he's alive I think I
saw a picture of it no really I don't
know where he is I never saw someone put
away a bottle of about acting till I did
it you know he was a really fun guy
everybody was great in this movie all
the castles there were a couple of
interesting music cameos that I want to
talk about it all mentioned Steve Jordan
yeah Jordan you know perhaps you won't
be greatest if not be in my opinion be
next to Flaco he's probably the greatest
and the guy with a pack everything so
quiet there you know and I off the city
great great Tejano accordionist to died
a few years ago
he's a Steve Jordan look him up aka
Esteban Cortazar yeah well hold on
the other one and because I'd seen his
name and when I was looking up to film
on IMDB I see this guy Larry Blackman
the nice thing looks like that can't be
Larry black men from cameo yeah catch
the guy who played the Bruce Lee he he
played that was a Jason Scott Lee Jason
Scott Lee became a Bruce Lee you know
Jason's coming yeah he was Bruce Lee in
them in their biography on the movie
biography Larry Blackman is the
african-american guy early in the film
yeah coin yeah that's in the girl that's
what happened
that girl eighties eighties R&B fans
that's the guy from cameo I have more
people ask me about that girl underneath
and that oh that's a funny joke when he
goes up
I have a black [ __ ] oh yeah I could see
that these hunter was to see which is
spectacular and that was a fun
auditioning process you know because it
was so a lot of girls it you know it
always ended up be too between her and
and Engelbert Humperdinck daughter oh
yeah yes what the hump and humper told
me they were but beneath had that that
kind of feline sexiness you know was
stop talking like a baby but it was that
whole opening sequence with the girl
walking around town and everybody I mean
I stole that directly from a girl can't
help it I don't know if everybody's ever
seen that picture they had all these
gags and so I won't do a thing like that
would have all that kind of gags and
that worked out really well it's been
influenced yeah that's what it's called
I've had influences yeah you produced do
the right thing you were involved
just like born in East LA I brought do
the routing in and got it financed yes
and born on the fourth of July one of
the questions I was another one after
this film got made and it was a hit was
a studio interested in doing more Latino
films it is frankly and I think
everybody here would agree it is always
a struggle I'm not gonna close it just
is but money but money talks that's
right that's the current right in there
and so there have been movies over the
years and it is I think as Cheech was
saying harder than ever yeah it's not
gonna it's never gonna get easier yes it
will
well I want Paul to be right
we're gonna coach know our numbers are
just too many you you they will hop on
the train like it's a business right as
soon as they see this is what baffled me
about this movie it made money so you
would think there would have been a born
again and he still there reborn
I mean people born again there is a
sharknado five come on well you know
it's interesting you're right
but this and if this was today we would
immediately becoming the second one what
was it before those sequels the sequels
it was just I wrote a script after this
uh and and and was called born again in
East LA and it was just it was a story
and I wrote it what happens can you tell
you saw you sitting on that script I go
to school and I learn English I think I
still have it but it was what it was
this is is and I sent it to the studio
and and it was the same time that the
last imitation of Christ the Last
Temptation the Last Temptation of Christ
came out of Marty Scorsese you know tell
me the ending please analyst and it was
like they anything and it was a lot of
controversy and a big flop and so
anything with any kind of religious guy
came back like a boomerang man you know
no no we're not doing any of those gonna
start all over and add a couple years
invested in this alright again is that
at that point Studios not the shine was
involved but they said Bernie still he
was a big yes well we really get what
you what you're doing and we liked your
storytelling I like what you're doing we
have the script and it's you and a dog
and you're a policeman and this is a dog
you don't get what I'm doing you know
teachers being he's being modest about
something
there's an enormous amount of creativity
in this man and what he's gone on to do
in the world of Chicano art oh he
it just really deserves a mention and a
hurrah and it's where you've taken so
much of your vision in your helping
other people and bringing artists in
front of the world there's no scandal
lobotomy there was something about he
said those payoffs no it's like I'm a
Chicano I have to have three jobs at all
times you know so it's easy to do that
so I wanted to mention a couple of
things
currently at Lac mother's an exhibition
of part of Pacific Standard Time
retrospective of the work of Carlos
Almaraz and many of the paintings in
that show come from a collection of
teach Marines so if you haven't seen
that show everybody go to LACMA and see
the Carlos on what I show it's the best
painting show you'll ever see in your
life on November 6th teach is gonna be
doing a sit-down interview with Michael
Govan the head of LACMA it's gonna be at
LACMA so please check that out as well
and if you haven't heard it's in the
program but you haven't heard and I
can't overestimate the significant
significant of this enough in 2020 in
Riverside they're going to be opening
the teach Writing Center for Chicano art
culture and Industry
[Applause]
so I phenomenal accomplish my it's you
know it dropped out of the heavens you
know and I finally came to the
conclusion that if your motives are pure
good things will happen I mean I've
always kind of gone gone along that line
and that's been my philosophy your
tensions are pure that that stuff will
happen and and it does it really does
before what do you want them to play you
in the movie of your life Jan Michael
Vincent before we wrap this up I just
want to switch gears for just a second
because a few months ago I had the
opportunity to interview Kamala and
Patricia Arquette about a documentary
that they worked on called equal means
equal and it's a really important film
and I want you to just say a few words
about that if you would thank you so
much well I found out about ten years
ago that women didn't have equal rights
in the United States and 96% of us think
we do so I spent the past decade looking
at the laws and how they work or don't
work and they don't and I've started a
new initiative this year to get the last
two states we need ratified before the
end of this legislative year so come
elections in 2018 we'll know which state
legislators actually support women and
which say they do but really don't so
please join me at equal means equal org
thank you very much
[Applause]
so I've always supported women I got two
of them right now house each but maybe
I'm wrong if you don't if you don't have
this for your archives yeah if you don't
have it you can keep it if you have it
you figure out who to give it to here
tonight oh really it's the single of
born in East LA accepting for mr. marine
Tommy Chong oh thank you very much
Wow so thank you very much thank you
Coppola Lopez Paul Rodriguez Thank You
Daniel
Cheech my team thank you very much for
everybody for coming tonight it was nice
to see this picture what hill thank you
and the legatus
[Applause]
you